There was yeah yeah yeah
me
[music]
Good Good Good
The light meat of the bird was entwined with the torotoro egg in the oil, but the degree of melting meat was gentle, but
he had a crisp eye and a high-quality body of a high-class chicken  It ’s a perfect fire to make the best use of
it. Then,
let ’s say until
it has a thick texture.  Senbei
Cooked rice, chopped and rika are thinly spread with sesame oil
and baked crispy. Dora crispy
also has a multi-layered texture Juicy chicken and offensive gear When
you go to get egg sauce and raw cat made from rice  The reason why the medicine is cloudy with three elements
and what plays a bigger role is
this route wrapped around the breast meat
.  It refers to the cinnamon that is rolled and baked. It is a
cooking method that can add color to the texture of the foot heat gradient. That's right, the
biggest secret of this monkey is there.
I mixed the ingredients with the crew that was supposed to be wrapped around the chicken in a
hurry. I wondered if the ingredients were
chopped and
peanut butter
.
It doesn't have an excellent secret flavor that deepens the blackness of chicken meat. It's
also good to have a moderate smile on the outside, but it
's actually extremely effective in connecting the agra flavor of meat dishes
.
If you ask me, it means that the human skin will be transformed in the day. When I go to the
main self-portrait, I get the crune of p.
By doing so, the deliciousness that echoes below will be enhanced to the main position.